hello there it's PS Plus update time
once again the mid-month update for
extra and premium subscribers to pile on
even more games into your library the
following games release on March 21st
which is this coming Tuesday and it's
another good month so let's do this Chia
is releasing straight into PS plus extra
day and date an open world Adventure
game where exploration and traversal is
the hook our character has a soul
jumping ability allowing us to take
control of any animal we see and get
this even objects too each animal we
control has a different ability like
digging if you're a dog or flying above
the trees if you're a bird there is a
story here too set on the very real
island of New Caledonia with hundreds of
unlockable cosmetics and useful items to
find in the world like a slingshot cheer
may be the break from other games that
you need plus there's a playable ukulele
will you try it it's a solo game
available on both PS4 and PS5 have you
seen Immortals Phoenix Rising a great
little action adventure game hugely
influenced by The Legend of Zelda breath
of the wild but the world is set in
Greek mythology and is narrated by one
God telling another a story of how a
mere mortal must defeat Typhon to save
her brother and they're talking about
you the combat is fun as it breaks up
the world puzzles well but the main part
of this journey is actually the comedy
this could not be further from God of
War's take on Greek myth instead Phoenix
helps imprisoned Gods out of amusing
predicaments that said everything we do
is linked to the real myths for example
completing a puzzle May reveal an image
and a companion will quickly explain
that Fable there's about 20 hours of
content to get through and review say
Immortals Phoenix Rising is a shade
under 8 out of 10. next a launch title
for the PS5 ghost wire Tokyo a first
person shooter but without guns because
we are using magic baby this game opens
with a spirit possessing us and the
adventure begins in abandoned sabuya
there's a few horror tropes you should
be aware of like jump scares buildings
morphing before your eyes headless
creatures walking around and creepy
voices in your head but calling ghost
wire Tokyo a horror game would be going
too far we slowly build up our spell
casting abilities which act like
firearms for example there's a short
range burst just like a shotgun and
there's a spell you can spam which is
basically having a pistol in a shooter
game the city we inhabit is unlocked in
stages as your skill set expands oh and
be ready to collect things from tanuki's
to cash to statues to unique items and
skill points if you enjoy collecting
things like a Ubisoft game ghostwire
Tokyo is your jam overall the combat and
missions do get quite repetitive quickly
but the City itself is amazingly
detailed and full of charm review scores
are as high as 9 out of 10 and as low as
6 out of 10. so you'll need to play to
make your own mind up before the world
went into lockdown a new Rainbow Six
game was coming when it finally arrived
it kinda went unnoticed and now it's
here on PS plus extra Rainbow Six
extraction extraction takes the
incredible foundations of Rainbow Six
Siege and morphs that realism into a PVE
Co-op shooter that is set in an infested
alternative reality stealth remains a
key mechanic as you and your squad try
to remain unnoticed while completing a
task taking out as many of these beings
as possible before The Horde are aware
and come running we must then extract to
keep everything we've earned in the
mission creating a tense backtrack to
the chopper Stakes become even higher
when an infected version of one of your
teammates must be fought and rescued so
if shooting aliens is your thing grab a
few friends and play Rainbow Six
extraction average review score 7 out of
10. Uncharted fans check out the legacy
of Thieves collection 2 two games in one
Uncharted 4 a thief's end and Uncharted
the Lost Legacy the playstyle of both
games is the same it's a third person
action adventure to recover treasure
interspersed with really cool puzzles
and pretty average cover shooting the
real draw of both games are the
protagonists and the worlds they visit
Uncharted 4 tells the story of Nathan
Drake's final adventure to date as he
and his brother team up like back in
their childhood whereas Lost Legacy
takes two of the best supporting
characters from the series and places
them Center Stage Chloe and Nadine have
such an amazing dynamic between them
that I honestly don't think you will
miss Nathan Drake let me know if I'm
wrong Uncharted 4 is the bigger game
with more bombastic action and will last
about 17 hours whereas Lost Legacy is a
shorter six to eight hour game with a
more open world section that could pad
out that time Uncharted 4 also scores
much high with critics with nines and
Perfect 10s out of 10 whereas Lost
Legacy is closer to an eight the unsung
hero of this month is Untitled goose
game and I demand you play it as this
title suggests you are a goose and must
wreak havoc on the town folk from
stealing glasses to Wrecking the
farmer's crops and better yet it has a
two-player mode I'll link a video of me
and my son playing to hit you in the
fields but you must play Untitled Goose
game it's amazing fans of Fighters
should take a look at street fight
Fighter 5 Champion Edition the
head-to-head Rumble Fest is as iconic as
always and all the characters you've
grown up with are here from Ryu to Chun
Li and and Dem thighs 40 characters in
total back in January life is strange
and life is strange before the storm
we're added to PS plus extra and now
there's another two life is strange true
colors and life is strange too their
adventure games which are more like
interactive stories true colors is
focused around Alex Chen who has a
superpower she can feel the emotions of
others around her the story is told by
solving a mystery and as this is life is
strange there will be a tragedy or two
along the way life is strange too tells
the tale of two brothers Sean and Daniel
running away from home pretty
hard-hitting and it just so happens that
Dan has telekinesis Powers story is
everything in life is strange and it's
super easy to get invested in the
protagonists four open world fans have a
look-see at Rage 2 set in the
post-apocalypse we are asked to be the
last Ranger of the Wasteland who was
left for dead and must take everything
back and more on release Rage 2 was an
absolute buggy mess but most of those
issues have been ironed out oh and the
vehicle combat in this game is pretty
good another open world game is Dragon
Ball Z Kakarot one for the anime peeps
the setup is quite impressive as we play
through many of the iconic moments from
the series not for you well what about
Final Fantasy type 0 HD we take control
of class 0 as they are thrown into
battle the combat lets three characters
in a party at once yet we only control
one with AI taking over the other two
with 14 characters in total there are
many moves to master yet it's the
interactions between the group which is
the most compelling as they uncover why
they are part of type zero Neo the world
ends with you is another action RPG that
forces us to compete in the so-called
Reaper games way before squid game was a
thing luckily we have immensely skilled
Fighters with flashy and stylish moves
and finally on extra this month is Haven
third person RPG which is more focused
around survival than the power fantasy
of the last few games playing as a
couple you will explore together fight
alongside each other and there's even
love scenes oh and cooking too maybe I
should have said those the other way
around and on top of all that is a
rhythm element to perfectly timed combos
together which is pretty cool before we
go let's go through the games that are
leaving the catalog on March 21st there
are nine leaving this month they are
Monster Energy Supercross the official
video game 5. Victor ran Overkill
Edition a velocity box ultimate bundle
The Vanishing of Ethan Carter override 2
super Mech League ghost of a tale
dungeons 2 and danger zone all leave on
March 21st and you may have already
noticed that WWE 2K 22 has already been
removed making it one of the shortest
stints in the service so far please let
me know if you'd like me to keep this
section in and keep you updated on
what's leaving the collection and
finally over to the premium games for
the month and the PS1 and PSP area
Bridge racer Type 4 was amazing back in
the day with mind-blowing graphics and
physics we've come a long way since
those days ape Escape 2 again for the
PS1 I thought this was a PS2 game but
Sony say it's PS1 so I Stand Down lets
us track down and catch monkeys in new
ways including over 100 mini games and
finally on the PSP is siphon filter dark
mirror an underrated entrance in the
siphon filter series and that's
everything that's 18 games in eight
minutes I'm completely knackered I'm
Adam you're awesome I'll see you next
time